and tell me what you think  reading that  you as the landlord are entitled to get  from  the tenant in the event of a tenant  breach  in the way of damages i don't have my  glasses i mean  i am at a disadvantage because i didn't  bring my glasses this is a small writing  yeah  another example the speaker may look  dazed or uncomfortable when someone  gives them something to read they may  just appear to be staring at the page  without any indication that they're  actually reading or understanding what  is on the page i bring to you again  another exhibit from donald trump  we can have a bigger copy made of these  pages let me try let me just do it  all right now you have to place on the  record a hearty objection